TREY: WELCOME BACK TO
"SUNDAY NIGHT IN AMERICA,"
REPUBLICAN HOUSE MEMBERS
UNVEILED THEIR COMMITMENT TO
AMERICA.
A SERIES OF LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS THEY WILL CAMPAIGN
ON BETWEEN NOW AND THE
MIDTERMS.
IT'S GOOD TO TELL PEOPLE
WHAT YOU ARE FOR, POLITICS
OFTEN DIGRESS TO HOW BAD THE
OTHER SIDE IS AND SCANT
ATTENTION IS GIVE DON'T WHAT
A PARTY OR CANDIDATE
AFFIRMATIVELY BELIEVES THERE
ARE CHALLENGES FOR HOUSE
REPUBLICANS, FIRST IS ONE
ROOTED IN THE EXPECTATIONS.
MANAGING EXPECTATIONS IS
CRUCIAL IN ALL FACETS OF
LIFE.
THERE IS A REASONS WE ADVISE
PEOPLE TO UNDER PROMISE AND
OVER PERFORM, TELLING PEOPLE
WHAT YOU WANT TO ACHIEVE IS
GOOD.
BUT YOU ALSO HAVE TO LEVEL
WITH THE VOTERS ON THE
LIKELIHOOD OF LEGISLATIVE
SUCCESS.
IF THE G.O.P. TAKES THE
HOUSE BUT NOT SENATE,
LIKELIHOOD OF SUCCESS IS
ZERO.
IF THE G.O.P. TAKING HOUSE
AND SENATE LIKELIHOOD IS
SLIGHTLY HIGHER THAN ZERO
BUT NOT BY MUCH BECAUSE JOE
BIDEN WILL BE IN THE WHITE
HOUSE THROUGH JANUARY OF
2025, REGARDLESS, PRESIDENT
BIDEN IS NOT GOING TO SIGN
ANY PART OF THE COMMITMENT
TO AMERICA.
THERE IS ALSO CHALLENGE OF
COMMUNICATES CONSERVATISM.
THEY BELIEVE IN LESS
GOVERNMENT, LESS REGULATION,
LESS SPENDING, LET FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AS OPPOSED TO
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
IT IS A BELIEF IN LESS FROM
OTHERS AND MORE FROM
YOURSELF.
MAKING THAT ARGUMENT IS HARD
TO DO IN THE CURRENT
POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT,
TELLING VOTERS WHO YOU
BELIEVE, SUPPORT AND DO IF
TRUSTED WITH THE GEARS OF
GOVERNMENT.
BUT TELL THEM THE TRUTH.
VOTERS APPRECIATE CANDOR AND
HONESTY, THEY DO NOT LIKE TO
BE MISLED, PART OF BEING
CONSERVATIVE IS SETTING THE
ROOT EXPECTATIONS, JOE BIDEN
IS NOT SIGNING YOUR IDEAS
INTO LAW.
BUT.
YOU CAN KEEP BAD IDEAS FROM
EVER GETTING TO HIS DESK.
I'VE BEEN WONDERING FOR FOR
OVER 40 YEARS NOW, LATE
1970S I WROTE MY FIRST
LETTER TO THE EDITOR, I WAS
ROLLING NEWSPAPERS IN A GAS
STATION ONE MORNING ABOUT TO
BEGIN MY PAPER ROUTE.
AND THERE WAS A STORY IN MY
LOCAL PAPER ABOUT U.S.
SUPREME COURT.
IN THAT STORY SOME MEMBERS
WERE REFERRED TO AS
ULTRACONSERVATIVE.
BUT NO MEMBER WAS REFERRED
TO AS ULTRA LIBERAL.
IT SEEMED THEN AND NOW THAT
THE EXTREMISTS ACCORDING TO
THE POLITICAL WRITERS COULD
ONLY BE WITH THE RIGHT, THIS
WEEK I READ STORIES OUT OF
ITALY WITH GREAT INTEREST
THEIR NEW LEADER, MALONE WAS
CALLED FAR RIGHT AND HARD
RIGHT.
MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE THIS
WEEK.
OF COURSE, SHE WAS THE FIRST
WOMAN
CHOSEN TO LEAD ITALY, BY
THAT WAS BURIED, IT IS ONLY
HISTORIC IF THE OTHER SIDE
DOES IT THE MEDIA REALLY
WANTED YOU TO KNOW IS SHE
WAS QUOTE, HARD RIGHT OR
QUOTE FAR RIGHT, THAT HAS ME
WONDERING WHO GETS TO DECIDE
WHAT IS LEFT, RIGHT OR
CENTER?
TO SAY SOMEONE IS HARD OR
FAR RIGHT, MEANS YOU KNOW
WHERE RIGHT IS.
AND TO KNOW WHERE RIGHT
S YOU HAVE TO KNOW WHERE THE
CENTER.
IS SO WHO GETS TO DECIDE
THAT?
TO MANY KAMALA HARRIS WAS A
FAR OR HARD LEFT SENATOR.
BUT NOT ACCORDING TO THE
MEDIA, THEY NEVER REFERRED
TO HER THAT WAY.
THE MEDIA TRIED TO CONVINCE
US THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS
A MODERATE.
COMPARED TO WHAT?
COMPARED TO WHOM?
THE MEDIA ALSO TOLD US AMY
CONEY BARRETT WAS A DEVOUT
CATHOLIC IN A BAD WAY AND
JOE BIDEN AND NANCY PELOSI
WERE DEVOUT CATHOLICS BUT IN
A GOOD WAY, SAYS WHO?
ACCORDING TO WHAT MEASURE
AM.
TREY: POLITICAL WRITERS?
IS THAT WHO WE LOOK TO FOR
DEFINITION WAS LEFT, RIGHT,
CENTER AND DEVOUT?
WHEN YOU READ SOMEONE IS FAR
RIGHT, OR HARD RIGHT, MAYBE
THEY ARE.
BUT TO KNOW THAT YOU HAVE TO
KNOW WHERE THE CENTER IS.
WHO GETS TO DEFINE THAT?
IF I CANDIDATE OR ELECTED
OFFICIAL IS FAR RIGHT, WHY
ARE LIBERAL POLITICIANS
NEVER DESCRIBED AS FAR LEFT?
IF YOU WIN AN ELECTION IN A
COUNTRY THAT TELLS ME YOU
MUST HOLD A MAJORITY OR
SOLID PLURALITY OF SUPPORT,
IF A COUNTRY SUPPORTS YOU
CAN YOU BE HARD RIGHT?
BECAUSE IT SEEMS THAT YOU
ARE PRETTY SQUARELY IN THE
MIDDLE OF AT LEAST
WHAT THAT COUNTRY WANTS YOU
TO BE, "NEW YORK TIMES"
DOESN'T HAVE A CLUE WHAT
CONSERVATISM IS OR
CONSERVATIVE BELIEVE OR WHY.
TO THEM EVERYTHING ON THE
RIGHT IS FAR RIGHT.
AND IF THEY THINK THAT JOE
BIDEN IS A
MODERATE, THEY HAVE NO CLUE
WHERE THE CENTER IS EITHER.
IT HAS BEEN 40-SOMETHING
YEARS SINCE I SAT ROLLING
NEWSPAPERS WONDERING WHY
THERE WERE
ULTRACONSERVATIVE JUDGES ON
THE BENCH BUT NOT ULTRA
LIBERAL ONES.
ONLY WE CAN BE FAR OR HARD.
NEVER LEFT.
MY GUESS IS THAT WE DON'T
NEED A FAR LEFT ULTRA
LIBERAL NEWSPAPER OR
COMMENTATOR OR REPORTER
TELLING US WHAT THE CENTER
OF THE COUNTRY.
IS BECAUSE THEY HAVE NOT
SEEN THE CENTER OF THIS
COUNTRY, SINCE I W